>>
So, introduce your company.
>> WHITE: Okay.
>> And a brief overview of the application.
>> WHITE: Okay. My name is David White. I'm
with FlightStats. We’re a data company.
We track about 150,000 airline flights a day
and report out on their status. We supervise
airport delay information, weather and airline
information. We also supply data to Google.
If you, if you type a flight number into the
Google Onebox or text the flight number to
Google SMS, you’ll get our data back and
response. We got enthusiastic about the Android
platform after supplying data to mobile developers
and some of the other popular platforms, and
decided that we were doing our app for Android.
It was an interesting platform play for us.
We were enthusiastic about the growth potential
and the growth potential worldwide as we supply
data for global flights. The development went
pretty well, surprisingly, quickly. The environment
was very similar to Java environment that
we develop our own apps in, and things went
pretty well.
>> So, can you tell us a little bit behind
your decision on the Android platform?
>> WHITE: As I mentioned, the development
environment looked friendly to us and familiar.
It was a good business decision we think,
even know the volume of sales on the Android
phones is low to date. We expect them really
tremendous growth in some key markets for
us. So, the technical decision was pretty
easy. The business decision seemed a little
risky, given the early state of the Android
platform. But given the announcements at the
I/O about the number of phones going out this
year, we’re pretty certain we made the right
decision.
>> Had there been any technical challenges
that you tried to deal with?
>> WHITE: Nothing really major. I think most
of the decisions we had to make were really
about user experience and understanding what
was possible with the Android platform and
the tools that were provided. Some of the
challenges I think we'll be facing ahead have
to do with interoperability with other apps
and the [INDISTINCT] and things like that.
>> Are there any new features in Cupcake that
you’ve been able take advantage of?
>> WHITE: Yeah, we have a version we haven’t
made available yet because the T-Mobile Cupcake
update, I guess, is not quite done yet. But
we were able to implement a widget for our
flight status application. So, it display
your safe flights on you home screen, and
with one touch you can update the status on
all your safe lights and quickly see how you’re
doing, whether your flights on time or delayed.
>> Are there any tips or tricks that you’ve
been able to do on the Android platform that
you haven’t able to do on other platforms?
>> WHITE: Well, the widget was actually a
lot easier to implement than we thought. Google
encouraged to us to do that to help them to
show off the widget capability and the platform,
and it turned out to be a pretty simple thing,
and we’re hoping that the users will really
like it and take advantage of that.
>> What’s your favorite aspect of the Android
platform?
>> WHITE: One thing that’s really appealing
beyond the widget thing is that you can keep
multiple apps open on your phone. That’s
the limitation I run into as an iPhone user.
Android get your past and so we’re looking
forward to interoperability with other travel
apps, applications that might help guide you
through other parts of your trip, might access
flight data and flight status from FlightStats
for Android and present it to you through
their apps. So we’re looking forward to
that, definitely.
>> All right. And other features in your apps
that's developed on top of Android that do
not exist on other platform?
>> WHITE: Well, so far, just the widget I
think. Otherwise, you’ll be seeing features
that you may have seen on iPhone travel apps
that use our data, but we’re definitely
exploring the platform and looking for us
from other opportunities to really kind of
plumb the depths of the Android platform.
>> Well, I want to thank you for time today.
>> WHITE: Okay. Thank you.
>> Great show.